bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée comme vous le savez
allait me savais que tu étais ce parti
dans le département tout de suite le
sommaire de votre émission sport
automobile oui un bertrand est à 13 ans
l'un des plus grands espoirs français de
cartes le pilote fans de sébastien loeb
a remporté le sens trophy 2015 et a
terminé à la deuxième place au
championnat d'île de france son portrait
dans cette édition box élan courtois a
dit lahm ou mady a remporté son combat
contre le hongrois torres marine le
samedi 28 novembre
pinault a terrassé son adversaire dès le
premier rand nous recevons a dit la môme
a dit dans quelques instants sur ce
bateau avec son coach jean guy farrugia
cyclisme le pistard de vélizy 78 jean
michel richefort 62 ans réalisé 664 km
pendant 24 heures à l'occasion du
téléthon
retour sur cette performance dans ce
magazine et puis en fin d'émission nous
parlerons en football et du match nul
entre verneuil et maurepas 4 buts
partout
il sera peut-être le futur sebastian
vettel ou lewis hamilton le jeune
viennois de 13 ans william bertrand
affole les compteurs dans les
compétitions de cartes patrick jacques
de dixmude pour les images
oui à bertrand 13 ans et déjà un as du
volant sans son permis en poche
ce jeune sportif né en chine et fait
aujourd'hui partie des trois meilleurs
jeunes pilotes de kart de l'hexagone
dans la catégorie cadet un sport qu'il a
démarré en 2011 aura su gare de cornavin
c'est mon père un jour on est allé faire
un tour en location et j'ai beaucoup
aimé ça et donc depuis vont aller plus
loin et on a vu la compétition et c'est
une grande passion donc c'est pour ça
que j'en fais ça me fait très plaisir
d'en faire
depuis cette saison la carrière du jeune
prodige s'est accélérée où liam bertrand
remporté le sens trophy 2015 a terminé à
la deuxième place au championnat d'île
de france
au total willy a réalisé huit podiums
sur les douze courses qu'il a disputées
cette saison et une grande maîtrise il a
une grande intelligence de la course il
arrive à maîtriser les compétitions à
savoir se repositionner pendant la
course
récemment dans un championnat de france
il fallait faire attention à la gestion
des pneumatiques il a su justement ne
pas toujours attaquer à la limite pour
pouvoir préserver la machine et espérer
être mieux dans la fin de la compétition
pour s'améliorer le jeune prodige
s'entraîne en moyenne un jour sur cinq
sur le bitume du circuit d'angerville le
pilote fans de sébastien loeb et de
vettel pratique également la natation la
course à pied des séances de musculation
pour supporter physiquement les
exigences du kart de haut niveau des
sacrifices pour se rapprocher de ses
objectifs
bref c'est d'être en f1 mais c'est très
difficile et donc pas déjà être en
automobile ces c'est déjà bien mais
c'est pour ça que parallèlement je vais
à l'école j'ai des très bons résultats
pro forma sur un bâton j'espère qu'il va
aller vers la monoplace et qui va
pouvoir s'épanouir dans le sport
automobile
je pense que c'est tout à fait possible
j'ai pas de doute la plus aucun doute ou
l'iem bertrand reprendra la compétition
en mars prochain son objectif sera de
terminer dans le top 3 au niveau
national lui n'est plus un espoir mais
une confirmation aux halles on parle à
présent boxe avec le champion d'europe
des super moyens a dit la môme a dit
nous continuons donc ce magazine par de
la boxe l'élan courtois a dit lahm ou
mady qui s'entraîne au palais des sports
d'el en cours n'a fait qu'une bouchée du
hongrois et ricqlès torres marine le
samedi 28 novembre
le combat était prévu en dire en 2010 la
n'a eu besoin que d'un petit rendre pour
terrasser son adversaire pour nous
parler de son combat nous recevons sur
ce plateau le champion d'europe a dit là
où on m'a dit et son coach jean guy
farrugia bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors ce combat villa vous l'avez
expliqué expédié très rapidement oui
mais enfin j'ai fait le bleu qu'il
fallait faire il fallait faire le boulot
qu'il fallait faire on a pu avoir le nom
de l'adversaire quelques semaines avant
et puis de là on a on a pu travailler
sur ces sur ses faiblesses et puis ces
atouts et vous avez peut-être mis en
place une technique pour le surprendre
dès lors du convent des bureaux est donc
là c'était simplement tenté de
de faire don de tout fait
légèrement dans un premier temps et puis
essayer d'atteindre les bas du corps
c'est un sacré morceau il fallait faire
attention parce que c'était quand même
il ya un bon il était gaucher déjà de
base
donc c'est une attitude différente on a
plus l'habitude de travailler avec des
droitiers et c'est vrai que il avait
aussi quand même une box assez
dangereuse mettait en avant parfois et
puis allez faire attention à ses bras
arrière donc on a on a travaillé tout ça
et puis ben ça ça a marqué des points
adil a enfin un tanguy a dit là à
réaliser le combat qu'il fallait il n'a
pas pris de coup c'est lui il a réussi à
le toucher comme il fallait donc rien à
dire vous êtes en dire qu'on va
peut-être si rapide si rapide non parce
que c'est un boxeur quand même qu'il ya
des champions du monde entier points qui
comme on appelle ça qui a rencontré les
meilleurs français qui a été battu aux
points et
lundi la bombe à la ridiculiser c'est ça
prouve que je dis là c'est un grand
mondial et vous sentiez capable de
réaliser ce type de performance un ronde
et qu'on va terminer il est capable de
faire beaucoup mieux encore faire
beaucoup mieux avec les deux autres
adversaires qui seront classés mondiaux
et voire même des champions dimanche je
suis qui je suis sûr qu'il va de
champion du monde donc son combat c'est
un petit peu préparés à la dernière
minute
à défaut de trouver un adversaire pour
votre pour le titre de champion d'europe
est ce que c'était un petit peu
frustrant 7 cette situation on rappelle
que votre combat avait annulé début
novembre
oui ça les dernières secondes avant
l'avant l'apaisement la pesée donc du
coup on attendait notre boxeur pour la
conférence de presse le jeudi qui s'est
pas présenté sa team était présente mais
lui ne l'était pas du coup il était
censé venir quand même pour la pesée et
on l'a jamais vu désistement le jour j
j'ai appris que je boxais pas après bon
frustrant on a fait comme le boulot
qu'il fallait c'est vrai que c'est
toujours un peu frustrant de savoir la
veille convoque sera pas après après
peut-être huit semaines de préparation
mais mentalement
strauss trek non parce que j'ai
confiance souci j'avais campiche comme
confiance en aux promoteurs
voilà donc il sait ce qu'est le boulot
il avait à faire quoi donc là on
on n'a fait que reporter un combat pour
moi et ce combat contre contre le convoi
était justement l'occasion de vous
maintenir en forme
voilà me maintenir en forme et de mettre
un peu aussi en dehors de mettre aussi
en place ce qu'on a pu voir sur ces huit
semaines sur ma préparation
et puis bah ça de ses fruits on suit pas
forcément mécontents contraire et puis
comme j un jeu fait qu'on peut
entièrement confiance aux promoteurs
il a quand même réussi à nous sans
forcément mettre ce titre en jeu il a
réussi à nous placer sur les dix
mondiaux sur les fédérations qui existe
en tout cas dans la boxe anglaise entre
autres wbc wba wbo et bien fédération
voilà les fédérations mondiales g j suis
classé donc c'est très bien après on
attend encore les adversaires voilà et
est-ce que tanguy est ce que vous pensez
que la dila fait peur parce qu'on a on a
du mal à lui trouver des adversaires du
stand la navy la voilà il a été pour
être championne pour être champion
d'europe il restait presque deux ans son
boxer là on n'arrive même pas trouvé un
challenger par dérogation après là on
aura des gros je ne pense que c'est très
dur de trouver des adversaires
les premiers comment l'expliquez vous
justement c'est un grand frappeur très
courageux il a rencontré de galles qui
est champion du monde
tu as fait d'ailleurs de galles il veut
pas faire la revanche entre parenthèses
donc
ça prouve que c'est quelqu'un qui
terrasse les plus grands mondiaux et qui
fait peur qui fait très peur et est ce
que enfin certains observateurs estiment
que adil a fait peut-être partie des
meilleurs boxeurs français actuellement
est ce que vous avez ce sentiment là
également entendu c'est le meilleur
boxeur français
j'en ai discuté encore avec des
personnes n'y a pas si longtemps ils ont
dit voilà même que même à malgré son âge
il encore quelques années à tenir et que
beaucoup regrettent commun signé avec
chatter promoteur italien
maintenant en france on a une personne
qui arrive à la cheville avec le
promoteur car qui donc
donc moi je pense je pense vraiment que
j'ai une grosse coeur tendre qu'est ce
que vous pensez que la diva est
sous-estimé peut-être en france dans la
boxe française et scoop
ils étaient sous-estimés et maintenant
ça serait difficile de le sous-estimer
voilà c'est la charente en espagne
champion de france deux fois perdu de
galles la décision beaucoup la comtesse
donc voilà c'est difficile de
sous-estimer m'attendre à un deal à deal
à vous êtes passé par des moments
compliqués et bien sûr cette victoire
pour le pour le titre européen au mois
de mai contre hilario et en espagne mais
vous êtes quand même passé par des
moments très compliqués dans votre
carrière vous avez 35 ans vous avez
boxer vous n'avez pas boxer pendant 18
mois par exemple à un moment est-ce que
cela enfin ces épreuves vous ont rendu
plus fort finalement oui enfin plus fort
dans le sens où moi je reste je reste
ici qu'à partir du moment où je me fixe
un objectif
le but est vraiment de l'atteindre sans
forcément me donner d'échéance voilà
donc après c'est sûr que c'est difficile
parce que on n'a pas
on n'a pas de date c'est forcément
toujours décalé on se prépare faut se
maintenir c'est ce qu'il ya de plus dur
on met beaucoup de choses de côté son
travail à côté exactement donc
d'ailleurs j'ai remercie bien d'avoir pu
justement ils permettent aussi de
d'aménager mes horaires pour pouvoir me
préparer sur ces grandes échéances et la
frustration aléas liés pas spécialement
parce que je me dis on le fera et je
mettrai les cartes qu'il faut pour y
arriver que ça se fasse dans un an ou
deux tant que je lâche pas bah on y
arrivera tanguy quel est le programme
pour la suite
pour adil a lancé plus nous qui décidons
il ya un promoteur maintenant ce sont
une défense de titre soir à s'attacher
du championnat du monde façon on espère
un championnat du monde et ont pensé que
ce combat le prochain combat dalila et
sera programmée prochainement vous avez
pas n'est ce pas rentrer bredouille de
là on va avoir une réponse le 3 le 17
décembre
on a une réponse fausse avoir signé son
titre en jeu dans leur antre janvier
février a dit là on avait 35 ans oui
quel est le programme est ce que vous
comptez à accrocher d'ici peu ou est-ce
que vous montez pour moi non je souhaite
le défendre maintenant
objectif c'est les mondes
et je réagis resterait du moi je
resterai dans le milieu tant que je ne
fais pas bon mon championne du monde
donc là on est je pense qu'on est bien
parti pour pour le faire voilà merci à
tous les deux est passé sur ce plateau
vous recevoir et grand plaisir lors de
votre prochain combat dit la merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce bateau en tout
cas on reste dans la boxe le verrez un
jour à ahmed el moussaoui 25 ans double
champion de l'union européenne des poids
welters s'est incliné aux points ce
samedi à hamilton en nouvelle zélande
contre l'australien jeff horn qui vit
noah a tenu jusqu'au 10e ronde avec une
blessure au biceps contractée pendant le
combat face au triple champion
d'australie de 27 ans ahmed el moussaoui
ne remporte donc pas les titres
intercontinentaux idf et wb aux
orientales le boxeur affiche désormais
un bilan de 22 victoires un nul et deux
défaites
la date de son prochain combat n'a pas
encore été communiquée après la boxe on
passe à présent et on ouvre à présent
une page cyclisme en un exploit
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le pistard de
vélizy 78
jean michel richefort 62 ans réalisait
664 km pendant 24 heures à l'occasion du
téléthon
retour sur cette performance patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images jean
michel richefort a réussi son pari le
pistard de vélizy 78 a parcourue en 24
heures la distance 2 664 km l'équivalent
d'un paris toulouse au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
entre nouveau en 10 4 et le samedi 5
décembre
un défi que le cycliste de 62 ans s'est
lancé à l'occasion du téléthon
à l'arrivée les jambes étaient
évidemment lourde mais le sort était
bien présent sur le visage du vénitien à
24 heures après c'est l'euphorie et on
se sent très très bien ce n'était qu'un
défi pour le téléthon c'est ma
contribution pour le téléthon donc on a
respecté à la lettre le tableau de
marche qu'on s'était fixés sur des bases
autant avait deux tableaux de marche
un tableau de marque réalise un tableau
de marche optimiste
et on est resté sur ce tableau de marche
oh et puis j'avais les jambes pour bien
terminer voire tout simplement
pendant son périple jean michel
richefort a connu une crevaison de la
roue arrière et un gros coup de fatigue
dans la nuit entre 5 heures et 6 heures
du matin
j'ai voulu résister au sommeil et choix
que c'est l'erreur à ne pas commettre
il faut savoir s'arrêter faire une pause
de 20 minutes une relaxation pour partir
j'ai voulu résister et ça a été très
difficile après je me suis refait un peu
en début de matinée mais j'aurais dû
vraiment marre était plutôt anticiper ce
sommeil je pense que j'aurais pu
atteindre peut-être 670 pour l'aider à
lutter contre la fatigue d'une centaine
de cyclistes amateurs comme
professionnels se sont relayés aux côtés
du pistard parmi eux stéphane rossetto
de l'équipe cofidis
yoann offredo et kévin réza de la fdj et
quentin lafargue de l'équipe de france
j'étais vraiment ravi de pouvoir y
participer en tant que accompagnateurs
un petit peu histoire d'encourager un
peu au début un peu à la fin et puis et
puis voilà c'est pour la bonne cause
donc tout et tout et tout est bon nous
on avait à coeur de pouvoir être présent
ici au vélodrome on y est tous les jours
on le connaît par coeur on connaît très
bien jean michel il fallait qu'on soit
là pour le soutenir
ce sont tous ces cyclistes confirmés qui
sont venus là parce que pour rouler sur
cette piste qui est très technique il
faut déjà être cycliste confirmé
l'exploit de jean michel richefort a
permis de récolter 7300 euros pour la
recherche médicale dans le cadre du
téléthon 2015
on continue ce magazine par du rugby le
club de plaisir s'est imposé ce week-end
sur le terrain de lagrange d'armentières
le score 29 à 13 pour les yvelinois
conséquence les plaisirs ou à son
premier du classement de la poule une de
fédérale 3 à égalité de points avec ris
orangis pour décrypter la première
partie de saison 2 plaisir l'heureuse
second sur ce plateau le coach du rcp
genlis bonsoir bord alors revenons tout
d'abord sur ce match est-ce que la
victoire était aussi simple que le score
le montre alors pas du tout va bien pas
du tout mais aussi à table et un peu
j'avais prévenu les joueurs parce qu'on
sait que en maintien d'une équipe avec
très lourd de 20 avec un bon pack très
très gaillards quoi c'est les gros du
nord m'a dit qu'on savait qu'on allait
tomber sur un gros pack on n'a pas été
déçu mag un petit peu l'organisation
heureusement pour nous mais sinon
physiquement et au niveau de la densité
physique c'était énorme
c'est très très très dur à répondre
présent au come-back et donc vous avez
pris le bonus offensif on prend le bonus
offensif mais dans les arrêts de jeu
avec ann daniels et les arrêts de jeu
néanmoins quand même avec une séquelle
sur le jeu depuis le 2 minutes et avec à
peu près une trés état de jeu donc un
bel essai demain et l'ouverture et la
victoire et elle parce que parce que
avant tient aussi bonne équipe de
fédérale 3 également oui j'étais pas
très très bien placé
c est en tout cas l'expérience de la
meilleure expérience et son expérience
notamment chez eux
on va dire et est ce que l'équipe est
encore perfectible
l'équipe de plaisir est encore
perfectible je l'espère vous l'espérez
jeu le secteur on y travaille on hydra
et pour owni travail pour dans quels
secteurs à d'un gars le secteur c'est
compliqué à se compliquer à faire parce
que à dire plutôt excusez moi mais on
essaie quand même d'apporter que ce soit
que ce soit frédéric ou moi on essaie
d'apporter un plus sur le collectif
c'est normal on est entraîneur on y ont
veillé à porter notre pâte entre
guillemets et surtout on veut essayer de
faire travailler les joueurs et d'un
pour qu'il en sorte un maximum un
maximum de résultats et de secteurs y a
pas vraiment un secteur on pas dire des
secteurs on travaille par rapport à
notre idée de jeu et par rapport encore
une fois aux éléments composent qu'on
possède donc vous êtes arrivé en
septembre à plaisir en provenance de
pontault combault
vous avez réussi là maintenant en
décembre est ce que vous avez réussi à
mettre en place vos idées de jeux wii à
certaines choses oui oui oui vous allez
porter peut-être notre patelin pour
aller à l'édifice et ma patte notre
patte on dirait puisqu'on est en les
travailleuses rails on travaillera en
collaboration et c'est vrai que
forcément quand on arrive on arrive tout
doucement c'est ma manière de faire et
on arrive tout doucement on aime pose
pas les choses on essaie de montrer que
ça peut être intéressant
au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai que il
ya un style de jeu on va dire qui a été
légèrement modifié sur certains points
et les joueurs et il y adhèrent c'est le
principal parce que si les joueurs ni à
des repas on se heurte un muret c'est
pas bon et votre projet plutôt tourné
vers l'offensive vous avez marqué depuis
le début la saison 2 109 points
est ce que c'est la force finalement de
plaisir ce jeu offensif
il ya l'équipe pour il ya l'équipe pour
une grande grande enthousiaste de la
part des joueurs tous les matches
bien sûr que c'est perfectible vous le
disais tout à l'heure et on est là
encore pour ça parce que je pense qu'on
est loin encore d'avoir obtenu le
meilleur de ce groupe parce que je pense
qu'il ya encore d'énormes possibilités
et on y travaille on y travaille et
offensivement vous pouvez déstabiliser
n'importe quelle défense de fédérale 3 à
votre avis assez prétentieux de dire ça
c'est vrai à dieu malgré lui sa majorité
donc dire que ça voudrait ça veut dire
qu'on est les meilleurs de france donc
sur les champions de france pour tout de
suite je reviendrai vous dire effectuer
or les peut-être un des meilleurs vue
pour l'instant les louer bon en tout cas
vous êtes premier de fédérale 3 pour
l'instant avec égalité de points avec
ris orangis
est-ce que ce classement est finalement
logique que vous descendez de faire de
fédérale 2 ou est-ce que rien n'est
logique finalement dans le rugby
oh on peut dire à quand même que ce
serait comme je vous avais dit la
dernier en fait plaisir s'est bien
comportée la saison dernière en fédérale
2 qu'il était logique de jouer le haut
de tableau en fédérale 3 c'est ses
forces et ses forces et maintenant vont
la saison de gorée longue
c'est vrai qu'on a fait un petit peu le
trou avec ris orangis
et donc on peut on peut considérer qu'on
sera on sera dans les deux premiers quoi
même si c'est un petit peu prétentieux
peut-être et présomptueux mais il faut
être réaliste on a le dernier match des
phases aller 10 matchs contre maisons
laffitte
à domicile on a vu toutes les équipes
sans vraiment sans grosse casse de notre
part ou vraiment ou alors une déroute
complète on peut on peut viser les deux
pour une des deux premières places et
réussir leur première et ris orangis
sera votre principal concurrent
fédérale 3 oui oui sans aucun doute il
n'y aura pas d'autres équipes qui
peuvent se mêler à cette course ou de
moi disons qu'on a déjà fait son âge on
a déjà sept points le crois de mémoire
sûr sûr sûr le troisième set puis bon
c'est quand même c'est quand même
quasiment deux victoires de différence
quoi
après je vous dis je suis pas
nostradamus et moi pour moi c'est
sportivement que je pense qu'on est en
est capable on est largement capables de
jouer on va dire en étant optimiste la
première place ça se jouera certainement
de toute façon à ris orangis qui est
quand même venu nous botte sur nos
terres 18 16 morts on a le sentiment
peut-être que cette année les joueurs de
plaisir on couteau entre les dents et
ont vraiment envie de remonter dès cette
année en fédérale 2 vous avez ce
sentiment là aussi évoluer ou la wii u
ils ont le couteau entre les dents je
crois que chaque weekend c'est ça c'est
leur dessert c'est leur petit gâteau
mais voilà c'est le travail de toute une
saison et puis surtout des phases
finales qui sont pas évidentes pour
obtenir éventuellement 7e place en
fédérale 2 si convoité donc l'idée c'est
de monter en fédérale 2 mais si
maintenant on peut maintenir cette fois
ci paraissait semaine dernière vous être
descendu après un an
là par contre ça sera de s'y maintenir
ses objectifs tout à fait tout à fait
c'est
pouvoir y monter déjà c'est pas facile
et puis après surtout surtout travaillé
pour y rester là c'est plus compliqué
merci à vous jean miss merci dépassé sur
son plateau bon courage pour la suite de
la saison ou sept
un dernier bon match à domicile du coup
en championnat
merci on passe maintenant aux autres
résultats du week end en football
l'équipe senior de maurepas fait du
surplace dans le championnat excellence
les remords oisiens qui évolue en rouge
sur cette rencontre ont été tenus en
échec 4 buts partout sur l'internet
stade du bout des clos contre l'équipe
de verneuil maurepas avait pourtant
idéalement débuté la rencontre en menant
2 à 0 avant la demi heure de jeu les
rouges ont ensuite encaissé trois buts
avant de reprendre l'avantagé dans le
dernier quart d'heure
verneuil a finalement égalisé au bout du
temps additionnel avec 80 14e minute au
classement mort pas et reste dernier
avec deux matches de retard le capitaine
mickaël delgado analyse le début de
championnat et championnat ratée de
l'équipe
on avait bien commencé la saison mais on
s'est un peu trop concentré sur la coupe
de france puis on a eu un petit coup de
mou depuis depuis le match de la cdb
qu'on a perdu en coupe de france
du coup bas avec les blessures et les
cartons jaunes qu'on a récidivé
on avait moins de joueurs donc les uns
un effectif assez restreint
du coup c'est ce qui a fait que
aujourd'hui même on est à 13 au lieu
d'être 14
c'est ce qui fait qu'avec un effectif
restreint on pèche un peu dans le
classement
là on travaille dur pour pour essayer de
remonter dans ce classement toujours en
football on jouait ce week-end le 8e
tour de la coupe de france le dernier le
dernier club yvelinois en lice le fc
mantois 78 qui évolue en cfa s'est
qualifiée pour les 32e de finale de la
coupe de france en éliminant le club de
l'as marck à domicile avec des buts de
près rae de masse en poo dans les arrêts
de jeu le club n'avait pas connu une
telle aventure en coupe de france depuis
dix ans on connaît déjà le prochain
adversaire demande sera le stade
briochin pensionnaire de cfa2 une équipe
que les yvelinois recevront à domicile
on écoute la réaction du manager robert
mendy second purge dans un musée reçoit
monture je suis parce que c'est
une équipe est dans nos cordes on va
dire qu'il ya une division d'écart ils
sont sortis brest aux tours que c'est
bon donc ce qui est une équipe qui est
sérieuse qu'il faudra prendre au sérieux
charme agit de coupe donc on est
contents avant tout de retour les 32e de
finale de la coupe de france se
disputeront les 2 et 3 janvier
handball masculin nouvelle défaite pour
le chesnay en nationale 2 masculine les
hommes coachés par yannis moralis
norbert se sont inclinés 33 à 25 contre
chartres à l'extérieur une équipe qui
lutte également pour le maintien
cette défaite a de lourdes conséquences
pour le club le chêne est désormais bon
dernier du championnat avec une seule
victoire en neuf matches disputés
prochaine rencontre pour le ch est né
dimanche prochain à domicile contre
saint nazaire on termine ce magazine par
des résultats de cyclisme sur piste
l'équipe
l'étape de la coupe du monde de
cambridge s'est déroulée entre ce
vendredi ce dimanche en nouvelle zélande
les pistards évinois n'ont pas brillé
pendant la compétition chez les hommes
le plaisir ou à michael d'almeida a
terminé à la 25e position dans le keirin
une épreuve dominée par l'allemand
joachim et leur ce dans l'épreuve de
vitesse grégory baugé qui est né à
maisons laffitte dans les yvelines a
terminé à une décevante 26e place chez
les dames la plaisir oise 110 claire a
terminé 37e de l'épreuve de vitesse une
compétition dominée par l'allemande
kristina vos gueules c'est la fin de ce
set 8 sport merci d'avoir subi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine très belle soirée sur tv fil 78